Ah, that's so cool!
Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to Devil Daggers.
Now this is a game I've never played before.
But it promises some run-and-gun action with some horrifying visu-- oh, hey... How's it goin'...
I don't like-- is that my hand?
But god, I hope that's my hand, because the alternative isn't gonna go so well for me.
HMMM...
A high-pitched ringing in the darkness, that's always good.
Oh, also. I got new glasses. What do you think? Are they good? Bad?
I don't know.. All right. Should I touch the big glowing knife?
Huh-UH!
I did it!
I did the thing!
N-NO! HAPPINESS AND JOY!
Oh SHI-IT!
OOH MY GOD!
AAAHHHHH!!!
UUUHHHH-!
AAAAaaaAAaAAaAAAAHHhHh!!
Oh my god, that's horrifying...
But I love it!
Whoa-hey-whoa-hey-WHOA buddy... Alright...
AHHHH!!
I don't like you!!
I fell!
I did pretty goddamn bad.
I need to spank the asses-- Oooh...
Okay, well, he-- WAAAIIT...
AAAH...
Good, chunks of meat!
Excellent AND delicious...
And NUTRITIOUS!
Ehhh! If the only these skulls had eaten their fill!
New high-SCOOOORRRE!!
AAAAHHHHHH!!!!!
So if I was supposed to rationalized some sort of...
S-some sort of LOGICA-- AAAH!!
SAAHSIVALDIS!!
[Word-of-the-day: Saahsivaldis (n.) - Evil spid-icle-pus]
I suppose I could go with the idea... that I'm in HELL!
That seems to be a pretty safe assumption in all these...
Uhh... endeavors?
Crystal! Alright...
And if I'm in hell, that means that... I did something to deserve BEING in hell.
And-- OOAAH! GOD!
Tit wankler!
Hey, I went up almost fifty thousand spots.
Well, that's nice. That's real nice.
*WEIRD SNIFFLE*
I'm in hell...
And I don't know what I need to do to try to persuade people that I don't deserve to be horribly maimed...
By demons beyond recognition.
Aaah!
Why do I gotta hit you in your red ruby?
NOOOO!!!
I can't get that.
Aaa-AAAh-AAOOOHH!
I don't WANT to get THAT!
Holy shit!
EEE-I'll come back for you later.
EEHHH... Maybe I'll come for you now.
Okay, let's go now.
AAAOOOOWWW!!!
Ow, I got titty-sprinkled.
Why am I here?
Can I go home? Please?
Hey, if you guys could let me out of hell...
Please!?! I don't know, I'd do a lot for ya.
Maybe take you to a nice picnic...
Give you a free movie pass... Gift card...
Alright... OooOO-AAAAaaaawww!
*Markiplier whining*
Why do you do that?
Alright. COME TO MEEEEEEE...
COME TO ME!
UUhhh... Shit.
I saw something at the darkness that I did NOT like.
Also what am I shooting?
What am I shooting out of my fingertips?
Besides just like...
I don't know.
Hot dogs...
Sausages...
Some kind of sn-- Aaa-AAAAH! Ughh...
Some kind of better-cheddar sausages.
I'm glad that I'm... permanently showcasing my skill for the world to... enjoy...
If there's one thing that people need to learn from:
It's all my mistakes when I'm battling hellish monstrosities from beyond the grave.
EUUUHH! YEEEE!!
Okay, those guys are a permeating constant threat...
And I need something better than snausages to be able to beat them.
Oh, here comes big bubble!
SNAUSAGE TIIIIME!!!
Ahh!
(high-pitched rewind) NOOOOO-WUAAHHN!!
Okay, so those assholes.... I need to take care of or else...
They're gonna get all mad at me.
I need to change their diapers real quick.
I don't like this!
I don't like this at ALL! What's with the green glow?
*Markiplier noises*
I'm getting bogged down AND overwhelmed...
Ehh.. My snausages ain't gonna CUUUT--
It...
OH!!
OOUUUU.....
I exploded into a Devil Dagger!
Okay, I'm getting better at sweeping across those guys.
My snausage capabilities have increased exponentially.
My hot dog fingers are really... really sassing up the place.
Hey hey hey hey hey, buddy!
Are you suckin' on my--
Woah! Are you suckin' on my rubes?
Let go of my rubes!
That's right, let go of my rubes! Some--
Oh, that is-- AHHH!
That is skittering demons on the ground!
AHH!!
AAAAAAHHHHH!!
UAAHHH!!!
♫ That is above my head ♫
♫ and above my pay-grade to ♫
♫ DEAL WITH YOU BULLSHITTERS! ♫
OOoooo! AHHH!
I'M OFF THE BAAAHHH~!!
*Exasperated sigh*
This game's hard...
This game's hard, but good thing I'm so PRO at games.
Pro at tossin' sausages.
Sweet, savory snausages...
I like the retro visual of it, but I'm a bit distracted!
About these guys that won't take my offer to go to FREAKING PICN--
GAAHHH!
Come on!
Whoa! Whoa, hoa! Hey! Whoa whoa whoa! Hoaahh auyg aaaHH!
AAAAAaaaAAaAAAHHHHHH!!!!!
(Voice cracking) Is the big guy dead yet?!
DID THEY--
AAAaaAAaaAAAAAAaaahHHHhhH!!!!1!1!
There's no way that I'm gonna survive!
WAH~!
I didn't- I didn't survive.
That was the thing... I did NOT survive.
I am SOOOO nice! There we go!
Yeah, I'm SOOOO nice!
So UNBELIIIEEEVABLY nice!
AHH!!
Am TWICE as nice!
Oh, I'm twice as nice! Please, just let me live!!
Man, if these denizens of the deep would just
LET ME LIVE FOR ONE GODDAMN SECOND
I'll be able to tell them how nice I am!
I'm giving you SNAAUUSAGES!
Show me your big butthole...
Give 'em back, give 'em back! No, no--
(Hellish) OOAAAAHHHHH!!!
(Laughing) This is hard!
This is legitimately hard! Like I know there's gotta be like...
There was a reason that Devil Dagger spawned...
So I can find out how and why...
Then I should be able to get it again and that will help me.
It's got to be the whole concept here, right?
Ahhh...
Okay, I'm just in try-hard mode, and I don't know why but I'm in try-hard mode...
And I'm gonna try hard until I try real hard enough...
That I win!
And when I win, I'm gonna kick their ass!
And when I kick their ass...
I'm gonna stuff 'em so full of SNAUSAGES that they're gonna be shouting snausages outta their eyeballs!
And that's not even something you shout!
It's like you gotta divide your focus between what you're seeing.
This game is ridiculously fun, though. I will admit.
Like it's something that's SUPER addictive.
Like... I KNOW I can do better.
And yet it's like SUPER twitch-based.
Very smart.
You got to do a lot of movement. It's exactly what I like out of a game.
I can't say that I'm the best at it yet...
(Across the board) OAOAOAAAOOAAAAHHH!!
Because I fell in a FUCKING HOLE!
If you would just
STOP
SHOOTING ME
IN DA HOLES...
YOU ASSHOLE!!
*Pterodactyl noises*
*Crazy Markiplier noises*
Aaieee!
NO! I fell- I FELL OFF!
I fell off into the abyss!
I'll never beat my high-score, but I'm gonna go for it.
I just gotta get.. another Devil Dagger.
Whoa...
(Thinking) Oohhhh...
That's... What?
*"Markiplier.exe" has stopped responding... Restarting.*
(Confused)
*Markiplier.exe loading... 0%*
Aaaaaoohhhhhhhh...
*Markiplier.exe loading... 7%*
*Markiplier.exe loading... 14%*
Aaaaaoohhhhhhhh...
*Markiplier.exe loading... 21%*
*Markiplier.exe loading... 28%*
(Silent gaping)
*Markiplier.exe loading... 35%*
*Markiplier.exe loading... 42%*
Aaaaaoohhhhhhhh!
*Markiplier.exe loading... 49%*
*Markiplier.exe loading... 56%*
Aaaaaoohhhhhhhh!
*Markiplier.exe loading... 63%*
*Markiplier.exe loading... 70%*
Oh, that's...
*Markiplier.exe loading... 77%*
(Silent realization)
*Markiplier.exe loading... 84%*
*Markiplier.exe loading... 91%*
(Silent realization)
*Markiplier.exe loading... 98%*
*Markiplier.exe loading... 100%*
AAAAAOOHHHHHHHH!!
*Markiplier.exe has loaded successfully.*
That's VERY useful! Why didn't I know about that--
Hah! 'Cause there was no tutorial, and I just held down the mouse button in a panic!
My just finger SQUOZE off there cuz I wanted to feed the hungry with the SNAUSAGES that I have!
Maybe like the point of this game isn't to hold down the spam, but to be...
Economical and intelligent about where you're placing your shots.
Cuz they ARE all grouped up, so you'd think that, uh... the uh... smart choice...
AWWWW!
It wasn't even going for me! It was LILTING!
[Lilting (v): to sing or play in a light, tripping, or rhythmic manner]
Confetti!!
It's- it's the party favor! BOOOOOM!
HAPPY BIRTHDAAAY!
Get your s-- Ow...
I give you snausages, you get me your buttholes!
Whoa, whoa, whoa! (x2)
AAAAHHH!
AAAAAHHHH!!
AAAAAAHHHHH!!!
Aaaaghh!
Oh come ON!
Aaaaghhh... I've got so MANY of those things!
(rageful rewind) AAAAAOOOUH-HUOOOAAAAA!
Let me just compare, I want to see what the best guy's done.
How'd the best guy do?
Let's see what-- Let's keep what kinda strategy he emplo-
*GASP*
Oh, he's not movin'...
Wha-WHAT? WHAT IS THAT SHIT?!
Where do I get that shit?! WHA~?!
I think his snausages are more powerful than mine are!
WHOAAAA!
Okay, spoilers!
Wai--
See, I only got two fingers out.
Oh, I see right-click brings them in.
So I don't need to go HUNTING for them.
I just got a hit right-click, and they'll come to ME.
Okay! I'm getting it.
I'm learning about this funkalicious game.
Ohhh, come on, I was doing great.
*Blowing noisy raspberries*
WHOA-OA-OA-OH WHOA! WHOA! WHOA!
Triple fingers!
WHOOOAAH! AYE!!
I'm powerful!
I'm REEAALLY powerful!
AAAAHH! NOOOOO!!
I was RIGHT THERE!
AWW!!
I beat my high-score by like A SECOND!
Alright you bastards...
Last attempt I've got on this!
I've been playing it-- WHA- WHOA!
Hey! WHOA! NO! I HIT REPLAY!
WAI? WAI? WAI-IAW ?IAW ?IAW
Goddammit, you sack of SHIT!
Oh, just let me ENJOY MY VICTORY!
Sorry, this is gonna be the last attempt.
Okay, got that. Uuuyy...
NOOO!!
God... COCK IT!
Noooo!
Whyy do I keep getting distracted by the goddamn buildings?
MMM... UUUGH. OOOHHH!
AYEEE! AYEEE! AYEEE!
AAH- AAAH! AAOOOH!
SHOTGUN BLAAAAAST!!
SNAUSAGE BLAAAA-- AAAOOOOHHH
COME ON!
*Exasperated sigh*
New high-score...
And what was with the whole spawning a devil dagger thing?
I don't understand that. Oh well, it doesn't matter.
So... That is Devil Dagger! SUPER FUN!
But, CRAYZEEEHH!
So, thank you everybody so much for watching!
I don't know how you would survive too terribly long in this one, but some people are BETTER than I am!
So thank you everybody so much for watching!
And as always I will see YOU... in the next video!
BUH-BYE!!
*Outro music*